creo que ustedes ya tienen bastante
familiaridad con los productos de
matrices por vectores en este vídeo lo
que quiero hacer es enseñarles cómo
estos productos nos permiten definir
transformaciones lineales de vectores
así que bien vamos a considerar vamos a
empezar considerando una matriz
que va a ser la matriz cuyas columnas
son de unos vectores columnas son b1 b2
así hasta bn tiene n columnas y también
vamos a suponer que tiene m filas cada
uno de estos vectores tiene entradas así
que va a ser una matriz que va a tener m
renglones y n columnas así que es una
matriz de m por el ahora voy a definir
una transformación t
que va a ir de r m
rm y la forma en la que la voy a definir
es la transformación t aplicada al
vector x al vector x en el dominio en rn
es lo mismo que tomar la matriz
qué es esta matriz que definimos acá
arriba y multiplicarlo por el vector x
en rn y quizás esto se vea un poco raro
quizás no sea el modo usual en el que
definimos las transformaciones pero
vamos a ver que esto resulta en una
transformación lineal así que antes que
nada vamos a estudiar un poco este
producto si toma la matriz y la
multiplicó por un vector x y el vector x
pertenece a rn el dominio entonces es lo
mismo que tomar esta matriz y
multiplicarla por algún vector x 1 x 2
así hasta x n
bien y cuánto me da este producto pues
me da x1 por b 1 me da x 1 por b 1 x 1
es un escalar y de 1 es un vector más x2
x b 2
y dos por b 2 y así hasta
hasta xm por the end
ahora bien cada cada uno debe uno
de 2 cada columna cada vector columna
hasta de n en dónde está pues estas
matrices de mejor en las y que tiene m m
entradas cada uno de estos vectores así
que todos estos pertenecen a r m y
entonces esto es una combinación lineal
de elementos de rm por lo tanto por lo
tanto esto está en r m
ok así que efectivamente efectivamente
estamos estableciendo una asociación
entre rn que es nuestro dominio
rm que es nuestro contra dominio
en el dominio y lo que hace es al vector
x el vector x en rn lo asociamos lo
asociamos bajo la transformación t con
el vector igual a la matriz a por el
vector x que ya vimos que está en r m
así que esto en realidad se conforma con
nuestra definición de función y por lo
tanto con nuestra definición de
transformación va de un rn a rm y en
realidad nm son generales pueden ser no
sé 3 o 4 o 25 y 37 no me importan lo no
quiero escribir en los términos más
generales posibles y quizás quizás estén
un poco o quizás estén pocos satisfechos
porque generalmente cuando hablo de
transformaciones de rn
rm lo que hago es escribirlas como dt x
1 x 2
y así hasta x n lo envió a el vector
algo como algo como así hasta que tenga
las entradas vamos a ver que este es el
caso que realmente esto toma esta forma
lo voy a hacer con un ejemplo concreto
muy bien vamos a considerar una matriz
muy sencilla vamos a considerar la
matriz de 2 x 2 b que va a ser la matriz
2 - 1
es una matriz extremadamente sencilla y
voy a definir la transformación
r 2 o r2 d2 en r2 mediante la
transformación aplicada al vector x va a
ser el resultado de multiplicar la
matriz b por el vector x ahora cuánto
vale eso tienes eso aquí tengo la matriz
b que solo lo voy a copiar acá abajo es
2 - 1 3 4
y la voy a multiplicar por el vector x
ahora el vector x está en r2 así que lo
puede escribir como x 1 x 2
ok así que hay que calcular ese producto
de matrices cuánto vale sería el primer
renglón por el vector 2 por x 1 2 veces
x 1 + menos 1 por x 2 - x 2
ahora la segunda entrada sería el
segundo renglón por este vector 3 veces
x 1 3 veces x 1 + 4 veces x 2
así que ese vector de ahí es la imagen
del vector x1 x2 lo puede escribir de
otro modo lo puede escribir de otro modo
lo puede escribir como la transformación
de x 1 x 2 es igual a
2 veces x 1 menos x2 coma
3 veces x 1 + 4 veces x 2 que es como
estamos acostumbrados a ver las
transformaciones así que en realidad en
realidad esto de aquí no es un [ __ ]
raro no es algo exótico es simplemente
un modo distinto más compacto de
escribir las transformaciones habituales
y la pregunta natural ahora es siempre
siempre que haga una transformación que
la defina como el producto de una matriz
por un vector me da una transformación
lineal vamos a checar eso ahora bien
pues les recuerdo les recuerdo que para
que una transformación sea una
transformación lineal tiene que
satisfacer dos cosas para empezar la
transformación de la suma de dos
vectores la transformación aplicada al
vector a más el vector b tiene que ser
igual a la suma de las transformaciones
a la transformación aplicar vector a
a la transformación aplicada al vector
de y la segunda condición es que si le
aplicó la transformación a un factor
escalar se por un vector
entonces esto es lo mismo que
multiplicar al escalar se después de
aplicarle la transformación al vector
bien estas son las dos cosas que tengo
que checar vamos a hacerlo ahora bien
entonces si yo tengo una matriz y la
multiplicó por un vector x vamos a
suponer que esto es una matriz de m por
n entonces como se ve ese producto pues
la matriz
la matriz se puede representar mediante
sus vectores columnas entre sus columnas
que son vectores de uno de dos
hasta
m
y el vector x el vector x para que este
producto tenga sentido tiene que tener n
componentes tiene que ser un miembro de
rn así que x1 x 2
hasta x n
cuanto me da este producto pues por
definición por definición esto da x1 por
el vector de 1 + x2 por el vector de 2
así hasta x n por el vector de n y como
ya dije al principio del vídeo esto es
un vector en r m sale entonces para
probar esta primera propiedad lo que
tengo que probar es que si tengo que la
matriz a la multiplicó por el vector a +
director de eso debe ser lo mismo que
tomar la matriz a multiplicar la por el
vector a y sumarle la matriz a
multiplicada por el vector b le voy a
poner un punto aquí para que no crean
que esto es una función que se está
aplicando a esta suma de vectores es un
producto de matriz por suma de vectores
ok y esto cuánto vale
esto cuánto vale pues la matriz a
habíamos escrito como la matriz con
columnas b1 b2 así hasta b
y el vector a más b va a tener entradas
a 1 v 1 a 2 2 b 2 así hasta en más de
simplemente se suman entrada a entrada
ok ahora cuánto vale esto cuánto me da
este producto pues por definición
esto me da
a 1 v1 por el vector de uno más a dos
los dedos por el vector de dos y así
continuó hasta
vn por el vector
n
esto simplemente es sustituir a x1 por a
1 v1 a x2 x a 2 por más de 2 etc etc
ok ahora bien yo sé que el producto de
escalar es por vectores tiene la
propiedad distributiva ese es uno de los
axiomas de espacio vectorial así que
esto es lo mismo que a uno por b uno más
por de uno
a 2 por de dos más de dos por dedos
y así
así hasta
por bm
más
bm por n
ok y ahora ahora lo que voy a hacer es
agrupar todos los términos que tengan
que ver con nada juntarlos
y escribirlos al principio así que esto
se convierte en uno por b uno más a dos
por b 2
y hasta
a m por the end
todo esto y ahora hago lo mismo
hago lo mismo pero con los términos que
corresponden
con este con este y con éste
y lo asumo no tendría
b 1 por b 1
de 2 x de 2
así hasta ahí no va a caber bn por de en
duras penas ok
y esto esto cuanto vale pues esto es
sencillamente la matriz
por el vector a1 a2
hasta de m
qué es el vector
más
la matriz am por el vector de uno de dos
hasta de m
qué es el vector de así que esto es lo
mismo que a por el vector a más a por el
vector de y por lo tanto la primera
propiedad se vale afortunadamente la
siguiente propiedad es mucho más
sencilla si tengo la matriz
y la multiplicó por el escalar sé por el
vector
esto es lo mismo lo mismo que tomar la
matriz cuyas columnas son b 1 2
así hasta n
y multiplicar la por el vector
sepor a uno separados y así hasta
por a
y eso cuánto es pues de nuevo por la
definición del producto de matrices con
vectores esto es
sepor a uno por el vector de uno más
separados por el vector de dos y así
si hasta se por n por el vector de n
pero pero de nuevo el producto de
escalar es con vectores tienen la
propiedad distributiva así que puedo
escribir esto factorizar la cee y
escribirlo como a uno por b uno más dos
por de dos o más bien perdón c por a uno
por fue uno más a dos por de dos más
todos hasta a
por d
pero esto de aquí esto de aquí yo sé que
es a la matriz a por el vector a así que
esto 3 me das cuentas esto es lo mismo
que sé
por la matriz o por el vector
y de este modo de este modo acabamos de
probar la segunda propiedad muy bien y
como se valen estas dos propiedades
entonces estamos listos para el gran
resultado este vídeo que es qué
el producto
producto
de matrices
con vectores
vectores
siempre
transformación
lineal
este es el resultado que estamos
esperando lo que nos dice que realmente
las transformaciones que definimos
al definir una transformación como el
producto de una matriz por un vector
realmente nos da una transformación
bueno y sólo para hablar un poco acerca
de las aplicaciones imagínense que
ustedes tienen su playstation a su xbox
o lo que quieran y entonces lo que
tienen son juegos que tienen gráficos en
tercera dimensión de modo que si ustedes
están parados aquí y digamos vuelven
hacia acá o se mueven hacia acá entonces
este cubo quizás no se vea
o más bien así o dibujando lo siento
pero el punto es que cambia la
perspectiva y entonces todos estos
juegos todos este tipo de cambios se dan
como transformaciones lineales que
veremos que realmente sólo son productos
de matrices así que realmente realmente
cuando tienes este tipo de cosas tienes
procesadores de gráficos procesadores
gráficos cuyo único trabajo es
multiplicar matrices estas cosas son son
calculadoras cuya única función es
multiplicar matrices porque si tienes un
chip normal un procesador normal pues
entonces tendrías que programar la la
multiplicación de matrices estas cosas
lo hacen automáticamente y es lo que
permite que tengamos todos estos juegos
bonitos y divertidos en el playstation
en el xbox o en lo que quieran pero
bueno esta es una aplicación interesante
de esto de los productos de matrices y
de las transformaciones lineales hasta
luego